there are so many new Beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products to test
for ourselves this is one of the
strangest new products I've seen in a
long time this is a hip dot icon baked
eye pigment Shadow I got the Share Bear
one these are essentially 3D figures
made of baked eyeshadow they kind of
feel like makeup Funko Pops like more
something you collect rather than use
but I used it the formula was actually
pretty dry it took me a while to pick up
any product on my brush I definitely got
a better application and color payoff
with my finger but still the formula was
dry and I was tugging at my eyelid which
I did not like this feels way more like
a novelty than an actual eyeshadow Fenty
released this double cheeked up
freestyle cream blush duo so you have
this baby pink color called Malibu's and
this deeper medium pink called peony
drapa I've heard that the Fenty Cream
Blush formula doesn't have the best
color payoff but these were actually
pigmented the problems for me started
with application I use used a dense
brush to apply first and it did lift my
foundation so I tried my sponge and I
think I made it worse my face was not
powdered by the way on the other side I
just used my fingers and that also
lifted my Foundation but way less I do
really like these Shades so I can see
myself using this on bare skin but I am
not a fan of this formula on top of
foundation I finally got my hands on
this 4-3 beauty honey pot lip care kit
it keeps selling out and now I know why
this kit comes with a honey lip scrub
and a lip mask this packaging is
literally so cute look at this tiny
honey dipper the scrub is like a regular
sugar scrub it made my lips feel really
soft but I wish it was a little more
coarse so I don't have to keep dipping
in for more this lip mask felt
incredible it's thick and smooth and
really hydrating and it tastes sweet
which I liked this is the Tom Ford
solanesh Lip blush lip balm it's this
transparent balm with a bunch of
platinum flecks in it it's actually one
of those color changing products so once
you apply it it turns into this deep
pink shade lip blush is a really good
way to describe it because it makes your
lips look so Rosy the actual balm
formula is really nice and hydrating but
no one on planet Earth needs a 58 lip
balm this is cute though Hollow Taco
polishes have been super popular since
they were released but I've actually
never tried them I picked up a few
different formulas to test out I really
did not like the skinny brushes these
came with but they actually sell wide
brush Replacements so I just swap them
all out this cream shade I tried first
was so full coverage and applied really
smoothly the color was just so rich I
got this iridescent flaky topper and I
was surprised at how much I liked it I
don't really do Toppers but this one
looks so Shifty and cool on the nails I
obviously had to test out some
holographic polishes both of these also
applied really well and had amazing
color payoff I had to turn my flashlight
on so you could really see the hollow I
applied the super glossy top coat on all
of these formulas and I really loved it
I like it when my top coat has an almost
Plumping effect where it makes regular
polish kind of look like gel and this
did that while making the manicure super
shiny overall I'm really happy with all
the shades I got and I can't wait to try
more this is the Milani days of disco
Shimmer spray it's supposed to be a
holographic glitter setting spray but I
was seeing absolutely no Glitter when I
sprayed some on my hand and I shook this
really well like for a full minute I
sprayed it all over my face and it did
make my skin look extremely dewy but I
still wasn't really seeing the glitter
effect I could only see if I was looking
really really really closely the glitter
effect is definitely not as noticeable
as I thought it was going to be and the
actual setting spray formula just made
me look oily
[Music]